[Música]
de frente no me van a silenciar
Bienvenidos a las plataformas digitales
de Rafael Moreno era un periodista que
se cruzaba todas las líneas sin ningún
tipo de temor y denunciaba absolutamente
a todos los actores que él consideraba
estaban involucrados en temas de
corrupción
[Música]
a Rafael Moreno Rafael Moreno Rafael
Moreno garavito hombres armados le
dispararon cuando se encontraba en un
local de venta de comida
Un minuto de silencio de pie por el
asesinato Cobarde del periodista Rafael
Emilio Moreno garavito le cayeron la
boca para que no seguía no siguiera
denunciando toda la podrida corrupción
que hay en Colombia
este panfleto me lo mandaron hace poco
en el papel me mandan esto
[Música]
una alianza periodística internacional
es de 30 medios el liderados o por
forbidden Stories de Francia que
continuó el trabajo de Rafael Moreno
contra la corrupción vamos a hablar de
esta iniciativa con nuestra primera
invitada del día y sobre la libertad de
prensa se conecta con nosotros Ivonne
Rodríguez ella es periodista del centro
latinoamericano de investigación
periodística el clip que participó junto
a cuestión pública a medio colombiano en
las historias del proyecto Rafael esto
junto a otros 30 medios nacionales e
internacionales Ivonne Gracias por estar
en directo a América
Buenos días Ángela Muchas gracias por la
invitación No gracias a usted y bueno
precisamente usted fue una de las
periodistas que llevó a cabo las
investigaciones de Rafael el trabajo que
usted realizó tiene que ver con uno de
los capítulos de este amplio esfuerzo
periodístico y está relacionado con las
grandes empresas mineras en Córdoba
región colombiana Y cómo están afectando
los derechos de las poblaciones locales
Quiero preguntarle qué fue lo que usted
pudo encontrar en cuanto a la violación
de derechos humanos de estos ciudadanos
si en efecto Rafael en su momento empezó
a documentar o advertir preocupaciones
sobre los impactos ambientales derivado
por la implementación de proyectos de
minería de Gran escala
justamente en el sur de Córdoba desde la
década de los 90 había una explotación
que comenzó con la explotación al cielo
abierto de Carbón transitó luego la de
ferroniker luego a la de oro y ahora hay
una gran coyuntura frente a la
exploración y explotación de cobre en
esta investigación lo que encontramos es
que hay una empresa minera que ha ido
digamos logrando varios títulos mineros
que justo se trasladan o sobre o se
superponen sobre territorios étnicos
principalmente resguardos y también
sobre comunidades campesinas sobre todo
mineros locales artesanales
principalmente en un lugar que se llama
la mina el Alacrán donde esas
comunidades históricamente han reclamado
derechos han resistido al conflicto
armado son víctimas del conflicto armado
y ahora pues se encuentran con esta
preocupación o pensión de que su
territorio sea ahora digamos explorado y
explotado en su subsuelo para la
explotación de cobre bueno en el
artículo usted habla entre otras cosas
Simón de la celeridad de las autoridades
para otorgar como nos decía
los títulos mineros no algunas de las
principales empresas que trabajan en la
zona frente a la lentitud que se da para
responder a los reclamos por ejemplo de
los mineros artesanales que han estado
ahí toda la vida Qué tipos de intereses
hay detrás hay que pudo encontrar usted
o que concluyó sobre los casos de
corrupción que denunciaba Rafael en la
zona
Sí ahí hay algo particular frente a lo
que tú preguntas al principio y es esta
enorme contradicción o el del
desequilibrio en la garantía de derechos
sobre las comunidades que habitan este
territorio que es diversa como decía Hay
comunidades campesinas y étnicas que
incluye también a las comunidades
afrocolombianas decir cuál es ese
desequilibrio Y es que en esta zona
desde que comenzó la implementación de
la ley de víctimas y restitución de
tierras se intentaba hacer el proceso de
restitución que digamos tiene una
continuidad con la implementación del
acuerdo de paz del 2016 y que en teoría
debe garantizar que se le puedan
devolver o restituir las tierras y
territorios que les fueron despojados a
las víctimas del conflicto Qué sucede
para que la unidad de restitución de
tierras y la dirección de asuntos
étnicos de esta institución que tienen
por mandato hacer este este proceso
necesitan una especie como de avales de
seguridad por parte de la fuerza pública
pues para poder hacer el proceso de
restitución es decir que existan las
garantías de seguridad para poder hacer
este proceso sucede que a esta
institución le ha costado un montón ha
tenido un montón de de tropiezos para
tener estos avales de seguridad para
poder entrar en el territorio documentar
los casos recabar pruebas redactar las
demandas presentarlas en efecto ante
jueces y magistrados especializados pero
contraste empresas mineras si han
logrado digamos acceder a títulos
mineros con celeridad para hacer los
procesos iniciales claramente de
exploración de minerales no claramente
Ellos tienen que hacer unos trámites de
Pues de gestionar la licencia ambiental
para poder pasar a la a la fase de
explotación pero es allí donde está
desequilibrio esto puntualmente en Casos
de restitución ahora para el caso de los
mineros locales y artesanales de la mina
el Alacrán que durante 45 años han
explotado oro de forma artesanal y es su
medio de subsistencia no han tenido una
formalización de un título eso les
genera una una especie de vulnerabilidad
y exposición
o de digamos sí de desprotección frente
eh a proyectos Mineros de Gran escala
como el que se está planteando en este
territorio
porque Pues digamos la empresa minera si
tiene acceso a títulos o a varios
títulos encontramos entre los hallazgos
de la investigación que esta empresa se
llama minerales córdobasadas que ya
tiene 23 títulos mineros y que espera
desarrollar un proyecto de Gran escala
que se llama el proyecto San Matías que
busca explotar
oro plata pero sobre todo cobre
Mire le quiero preguntar por algo
particular ibone Y eso es cómo fue
retomar Las investigaciones que dejó
adelantadas Rafael y hacer una
continuación de este trabajo porque pues
es que no es poca cosa Rafael lo mataron
por su trabajo entonces pues no solo es
una gran responsabilidad sino es un
riesgo a título personal para usted y
para los demás periodistas que asumieron
la tarea de continuar esto de trabajo
por la libertad de prensa
Sí yo creo que es importante Resaltar
que este fue un trabajo colaborativo en
el que participamos 30 medios nacionales
e internacionales
con un trabajo digamos en Red sobre dos
grandes temas digamos no no solamente
desarrollamos investigación periodística
sobre los temas de tierras y minería
sino también con mucho foco en la
revisión y el seguimiento a los recursos
públicos a casos posibles casos de
corrupción en en el uso de estos
recursos que llegan a este territorio
provenientes de las regalías
precisamente derivados de la de la que
son ingresos que se derivan de la
explotación minera energética y del
dinero que ha llegado para la
implementación del acuerdo de paz lo que
decimos las plazas de la paz lo que
encontraron Las investigaciones de los
colegas es que desafortunadamente estos
recursos
han sido desviados no se han terminado
las obras
digamos hay una especie de cadena de
beneficio de algunos sectores políticos
de de o clanes políticos que están en
este territorio
que se quedan con los recursos no
terminan las obras y esto Pues se ve
representado en que es una un territorio
y una población que no supera sus
necesidades básicas insatisfechas no es
una población que vive en unas
condiciones de pobreza casi de miseria
que que contrasta no con la riqueza que
hay en el territorio y que por el
contrario Debería ser poblaciones que
tuvieran una alta calidad de vida Cuando
cuando no está ocurriendo así creemos
que este ejercicio periodístico que hizo
un esfuerzo enorme lo que logra es
digamos dejar un mensaje importante y es
que en los territorios donde
se ha intentado silenciar la prensa El
periodismo de investigación el
periodismo independiente ha intentado
poner los reflectores y decir vamos a
poner luz sobre esas realidades que
quieren bueno justamente sobre eso es
que cuando uno realiza un trabajo
periodístico de esta envergadura con
tantos medios aliados lo que Espera es
que se genere algún impacto Y algún
cambio no aquí lo que estamos viendo Es
como siempre las comunidades más
vulnerables son las más afectadas y las
que están perdiendo los recursos y el
reconocimiento sobre todo el respeto a
los Derechos Humanos
Ivonne Cuál es la repercusión que usted
espera no solamente de su trabajo sino
del trabajo aunado del consorcio de 30
medios nacionales e internacionales ya
ha visto algo que cambie
pues es el trabajo se publicó el 18 o
sea hace apenas dos días pero yo creo
que la motivación y Y esa energía que
unió que nos unió a tantos colegas con
distintas habilidades de investigación
no porque aquí estuvimos reporteras
reporteros desarrolladores web
ingenieros web expertos en datos
productores audiovisuales no con
distintas narrativas sobre estos dos
grandes temas como decías sobre
contratación y el tema de tierras
minería es que estamos convencidos de
que el periodismo es un guardián de la
democracia y aunque propiamente nosotros
no no ejercemos justicia si ejercemos a
través de las historias una veduría un
control una visibilidad como decía hace
un momento poner luz sobre un territorio
que ha querido ser silenciado que está
en medio de unas disputas territoriales
muy complejas también por efectos del
conflicto desafortunadamente el sur de
Córdoba es una especie de puerta que
conecta un gran corredor que se disputan
estructuras criminales porque lo que
allí es como una especie de puerta que
conecta la subregión del bajo cauca
antioqueño con el urabá entonces la las
comunidades están en medio de unas
condiciones bastante difíciles no que ha
sido de supervivencia y de resistencia
al conflicto mismo entonces este esta
motivación como decía hace un momento de
que el periodismo es un guardián de la
Democracia nosotros lo que esperamos es
que el estado y con las instituciones
que deben garantizar la protección y la
garantía de derechos tomen decisiones en
función de eso que por ejemplo en el
caso puntual de de este tema de las
tierras y de la minería los jueces y
magistrados y magistradas especializadas
que vayan a estudiar estos casos
tengan elementos para tomar decisiones
de fondo sobre lo que han reclamado
históricamente las comunidades y en el
caso de los recursos públicos sin duda
que haya una real aplicación de que es
lo público cierto
que sea en función de la garantía de
derechos pues para satisfacer
temas tan básicos como la salud el
acceso a la salud a la educación no a la
infraestructura de Derechos Humanos